it's that time of the election cycle
again conventions and yeah recent
conventions haven't been all that
exciting especially considering that
each party pretty much identifies their
candidate long before the big event but
it hasn't always been this way here are
three of the craziest conventions in US
history the 1924 Democratic National
Convention was coined as the clan beat
that's because frontrunner William G
McAdoo had the undying support of
everyone's favorite hate group the Ku
Klux Klan but New York Governor Alfred
Smith gave McAdoo a run for his money it
was the longest political convention in
history 103 ballots spans 16 sweaty
summer days filled with fistfights and
screaming matches at one point 20,000
Klansmen gathered in nearby New Jersey
to burn crosses and effigies of Governor
Smith after nearly a hundred ballots and
no end in sight
both McAdoo and Smith dropped out of the
race so who won compromise candidate
John W Davis at the 1952 Republican
convention old guard conservative Robert
a Taft squared off against a more
moderate Dwight D Eisenhower aka I I
said he'd been steamrolled by Taft in
the southern states and that his
delegates were frauds Taft and his
supporters fought for his delegates to
remain but lost giving Ike the advantage
in a last-ditch effort senator Dirksen
tried to convince those delegates that
Ike a moderate couldn't win the general
election we followed you before and you
took us down the road to the beach and
don't do this
but the convention voted to follow
Eisenhower who went on to win the
presidency but nothing compares to the
chaos that erupted in 1968 the debate
over the ongoing Vietnam War took center
stage during the Democratic convention
thousands of people hit the streets to
protest they were met with police
wielding batons and tear gas canisters
inside the event supporters of anti-war
candidates Eugene McCarthy and the
recently in fascinated Robert F Kennedy
clashed with those backing pro-war
Hubert Humphrey in the end the
establishment one and Humphrey came out
on top these days we have a primary
system that makes convention drama a lot
less likely but not impossible and given
the current political climate in the US
could history repeat itself